Major General Gregory Lusk joins us now
from the North Carolina National Guard
joint force headquarters in Raleigh
general good morning hey good morning to
you so tell us what you're seeing on the
ground well uh I have the fortune of
obviously being in Raleigh North
Carolina so I am nowhere near the the
scenes of the reporting that that you've
just covered but having having had the
experience throughout my career I can
only imagine what they're indeed they
are reporting so right now in Raleigh
things are kind of calm but south
eastern part of the state obviously
quite a bit different over the next two
days you're gonna have a lot of work
maybe even longer than that what is the
first order of business as this storm
moves through well I think that if you
don't mind I just want to recognize the
the fact that so many of the the people
that they were just being reported upon
as being potential victims those very
people were a lot of them are on duty
today somewhere in the North Carolina
Emergency Management Enterprise
Guardsmen included so uh indeed just
tremendous and selfless individuals that
have left their homes and their families
behind in order to take care of the
needs of others but our first order of
business obviously was getting
pre-positioned
so that indeed we could immediately
respond to the life-saving methods and
measures right out right at the
beginning and then of course be posture
for what we anticipate is going to be a
very long recovery so we can try to get
North Carolina and all of our fellow
citizens our neighbors our family and
our friends back on their feet just as
quickly as we possibly can Major General
given the sheer size of this storm
larger than the Carolinas how can you
make sure that your troops the national
guardsmen are being deployed where
they're needed the most well I
appreciate that question and and you're
right there's a lot of it is is almost
on the on the level of unimaginable so
if we just have to imagine that the best
we can and try to establish as much
flexibility as we can as we do our
planning so we have quite a few on over
500 that are actually committed in
assigned to missions particularly in the
Eastern branch of the North Carolina
Emergency Management east of i-95 let's
say we have quite a
large number of people that we were
holding in what we call reserves about
2,000 or so that are kind of west of
i-95 all the way across the state all
the way to the mountains because as the
storm track shows I don't think there's
going to be any part of North Carolina
that will be unscathed and also it's
important to note that of course the
north us Northern Command and and our
partners are the rest of our army and
our Air Force of course our pre
positioning a lot of assets on the
periphery of the southeast region so
that ad we can call upon them once this
storm lifts and and utilize the
resources that they have a massive storm
Major General in your right to give a
shout out to all of those first
responders who are leaving their
families behind now many of them facing
this storm as well they're jumping into
the line of duty to rescue so many thank
you so much we appreciate it